YOU'VE HEARD TRUMP'S WORDS, I'M
SURE, UNEDITED, HOW DID YOU FEEL
HEARING THAT?
>> WELL, OBVIOUSLY, IT WAS VERY
OFFENSIVE.
HOWEVER, I THINK IT'S TOTALLY
IRRELEVANT.
IT WAS SO LONG AGO.
AND I DO BELIEVE MOST MEN WILL
TALK ABOUT WOMEN IN WAYS THEY
WOULD NEVER TALK ABOUT PUBLICLY.
AND, OF COURSE, IF THEY WOULD
HAVE KNOWN THAT THEY WERE BEING.
HERE'S WHY, HERE'S WHY, BECAUSE
OF THE ISSUES.
NOBODY IS PERFECT.
HERE'S THE ISSUES.
LAST NIGHT IN THAT DEBATE, THEY
DEFINE THEIR ISSUES.
THEY LINE THE MARKS IN THE SAND.
NUMBER ONE, ROE V. WADE.
HILLARY CLINTON DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT MURDERING BABIES,
DISMEMBERING ABORTIONS.
THAT'S OKAY WITH HER.
>> WAIT A SECOND.
>> RELIGIOUS FREEDOM --
>> WE'RE TALKING --
>> OH, YES, YES.
>> I APPRECIATE YOU TALKING
ABOUT SUBSTANCE, AND THAT IS
IMPORTANT, BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT LOCKER ROOM CONVERSATION.
MY QUESTION WAS ABOUT, IS IT
OKAY THAT A MAN WHO WANTS TO BE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE FREE WORLD
IS BRAGGING, AND ADMITS TO IT,
AND YES, HE'S APOLOGIZED, TO
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
>> BUT, YES, THAT IS -- THAT IS
WRONG, ABSOLUTELY.
BUT HERE'S THE THING, HE'S NOT
RUNNING TO BE THE POPE.
LOOK AT THE CULTURE OF OUR
COUNTRY.
EVERYBODY KNEWADORE.
AND IT'S REPULSIVE WHAT HAS BEEN
SAID.
THIS WHOLE CAMPAIGN, THIS IS THE
PERSON THAT NEEDS TO LEAD OUR
COUNTRY.
GOD CAN USE ANYBODY.
HE USED THE HARLETTS AND THAT'S
OKAY.
IT'S ALL ABOUT WHAT GOD>> ABSOL.
THEY ARE.
JUST LIKE HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
>> RIGHT.
BUT THE THINGS --
>> IT'S ALL A PART OF IT.
>> -- FROM THIS ADULT MAN WHO IS
RUNNING TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, MILLIONS OF
CHILDREN HEARD THAT, BOYS AND
GIRLS.
AND BOYS MAY TAKE THEIR CUES
FROM THIS GUY WHO WANTS TO BE
OUR PRESIDENT.
AND BHAF BEHAVE IN ACCORDANCE --
>> WHEN BILL CLINTON WAS
PRESIDENT, MY CHILDREN CAME HOME
FROM SCHOOL AND THEY HAD NO IDEA
IT WAS ACTUALLY CALLED THE OVAL
OFFICE.
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS CALLED THE
ORAL OFFICE BECAUSE OF THE TALK
IN THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS.
OKAY, BILL CLINTON EDUCATED MY
CHILDREN AT A MUCH YOUNGER AGE
THAN I WANTED TO.
>> BUT BILL CLINTON ISN'T
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW.
>> EXACTLY.
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT